la invasión rusa de ucrania podría
servir como una excusa además de kiev
otros dos países han solicitado su
adhesión en la unión europea moldavia y
georgia si bien las autoridades europeas
han dado luz verde a la adopción de un
estatus de candidato para moldavia
gracias a las garantías de estabilidad
de sus instituciones
georgia tendrá que esperar y sobre todo
transformarse y dice este es un gran
paso de adelante para que georgia tenga
una perspectiva europea es un gran paso
adelante las puertas están abiertas de
par en par ahora le toca a georgia
iniciar los cambios necesarios sustento
necesario steps to move power tres
nuevos países se han añadido a la larga
lista de naciones que desean ingresar en
la unión europea naciones que se
encuentran en diferentes etapas de su
proceso pero que aprovecharían la
situación en ucrania para acelerar las
conversaciones ese es el caso de albania
y montenegro sus líderes se reunieron
con volodymyr selenski en kiev más
ampliamente hay todo un grupo de países
de los balcanes occidentales que desean
acelerar su proceso de adhesión y
albania bosnia-herzegovina serbia
montenegro macedonia del norte y kosovo
algunos llevan negociando desde 2012 o
2014 como es el caso de serbia y
montenegro otros han firmado acuerdos de
estabilización que refuerzan su
cooperación con la unión como kosovo y
bosnia pero existe un doble rasero en
los países candidatos algunos líderes
europeos están convencidos de ello
está bien que ucrania tenga el estatus
de candidato pero todos sabemos que no
es la gran cosa puedes estar atrapado en
este estatus durante 20 años como
macedonia
esta forma pero es un paso adelante pero
qué pasa con bosnia es un país peligroso
lleno de armas hay riesgo de conflicto
armado no la respuesta es no
diane schuur es negro para tratar de
responder a estas preocupaciones los
líderes de los balcanes occidentales
serán invitados a una reunión al margen
de la próxima cumbre de la unión europea
que se celebrará el 23 de junio